back to those elites for me the most
important term is not actually the elite
you could be part of the elite and still
be on the side of the people
but elitism elitism is an ideology that
prioritizes the interests of those at
the top and it's been the dominant
ideology in American politics for the
last few decades a big part of elitism
is globalism the idea that we should put
some vague notion of the global interest
ahead of the national interest now
there's a story this week that is a
perfect encapsulation of elitist
globalist thinking and I want to start
with it tonight it was reported that
tech giant Google is working with the
Chinese government to develop a search
engine that implements the regime's
censorship of information it doesn't
like this is part of Google's plan to
get back into China after it pulled out
in 2010 in protest at the Chinese
government's hacking of Gmail this story
is very personal for me the China part
is personal because my parents are
Hungarian I know all about oppressive
communist regimes and believe me that's
what today's China is the Google part is
personal because my wife once worked
there and we now have a very comfortable
life as a result some of Google's top
executives are close friends but you
know me by now when I think something is
wrong I'll say so whomever it may offend
and this is not just wrong it's shameful
of course it's not the whole story about
Google I use Google all the time I'm
sure you do too
it's important to be fair and reasonable
Google's products are useful and that's
why it's grown so big but it's because
it got so big that Google is now not
just useful but dangerous too it is a
leading force for elitism and globalism
it's the essence of globalism that
businesses have no loyalty to their home
country for more than most corporations
America really is Google's home did you
know that Google got started thanks to a
program run by the US government Google
wouldn't exist if it wasn't for American
taxpayers Google once said its mission
was to organize the world's information
and make it universally accessible its
motto was don't be evil but now they
floated off in a giant balloon
arrogance untethered to any notions of
loyalty or ethics Google is helping
America's number one enemy the evil
communist dictatorship in China to
oppress its own people through
censorship literally the exact opposite
of what Google once stood for remember
too that Google has built an artificial
intelligence center in Beijing even
though the Chinese regime is openly
saying it will use artificial
intelligence to achieve military and
economic dominance over America on top
of that Google recently pulled out of
helping our own Defense Department with
artificial intelligence so Google born
of a US government program won't work
with our government to defend democracy
but it's falling over itself to work
with the world's worst despots to crush
democracy I know the word treason is
thrown around too much these days but
that seems like a pretty good definition
of it to me this is Google's CEO sundar
pichai someone I know personally and now
I'm talking to you sundar directly if
you go through with this it will show
the world that you no longer believe in
your own mission of making information
available you just want to make more
money available to you it will expose
all those sanctimonious high-minded
tweets and statements about human rights
and standing up for values as pure BS it
will confirm that Google is driven by
one thing maximizing GCP greed control
power of course you wouldn't come on
this show to defend yourself and I know
why partly you just refuse to be
accountable but there's a worse reason
China told you not to talk about this
you're not only working with the
communist dictators to censor in China
you're doing their bidding by censoring
yourself in America if you go ahead with
this I will come after you with
everything I've got and I won't be the
only one but there is still time for you
to change don't do this do the right
thing in a phrase don't be evil
all right follow us at next Rev FNC and
that's Steve Hilton X and let us know
what do you think